[Musik]
während der pandemie haben wir wieder
begonnen zu träumen von weniger
arbeitsbelastung und mehr sozial zeit
von sauberer luft und entschleunigung
doch die aufbruchsstimmung gerät leicht
ins stottern wenn der autor von sita hat
das gilt nicht nur für sie und mich das
gilt auch für uns aus gesellschaft wie
träume belastbarer werden als schäume
das weiß der kulturwissenschaftler jörg
metelmann mit dem ich nachher gleich
sprechen zuerst es mir jetzt aber die
politik ökonomie in marköbel aus berlin
zugeschaltet
ihr buch unsere welt neu denken steht
seit über einem jahr auf der
spiegel-bestsellerliste ganz herzlich
willkommen frau dipl
vielen dank vergleich ja frau göbel
unsere welt neu denken das ist vor allem
eines nämlich groß gedacht sie wollen
nicht ihr dorf oder ihre stadt irland
oder von mir aus europa neu denken
sondern gleich die ganze welt braucht
zukunftsfähiges denken diesem global
zuschnitt ich glaube ich komme ja so aus
einer bestimmten perspektive und die
beschäftigt sich tatsächlich mit der
globalen entwicklung und der großen
frage nach wie können wir die
nachhaltigkeit da rein bekommen also die
nicht nachhaltige entwicklungstrends die
wir seit 30 40 50 jahren dokumentieren
sind in vielen bereichen auch nur global
zu lösen
und vor allem haben wir ja auch eine
bestimmte form und vorstellung von guter
entwicklung sehr stark globalisiert
besonders in der zweiten hälfte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts und daneben
bemerkt was ist für konsequenzen gerade
auf unsere ökosysteme hat und deshalb
jahr kommen denn leider nicht darum
herum das groß zu denken und
gleichzeitig kann es ja auch
inspirierend sein und historisch
betrachtet ist es jetzt auch nicht
ungewöhnlich also haben wir zeiten der
aufklärung gehabt wir nennen das auch
manchmal große transformation wo
wirklich sehr viel neu konfiguriert
wurde inklusive der geistigen landkarten
mit denen wir eigentlich zukunft
gestalten
trotzdem ist es ja so dass wir
feststellen china denkt anders als
europa im silicon valley denkt man
anders als vielleicht auf einer
waldorfschule
das heißt meine frage wäre dann wie kann
man die welt neu denken denn hier schon
feststellen dass sie uns uneins sind
beim menschen will zb
denken die den menschen zum beispiel
stärker vom individuum her oder stärker
von kollektiv hoch spannend ist ja dass
die kinder aus dem silicon valley gern
auf waldorfschulen einmal ganz ganz
spannend zu beobachten und die frage
nach dem menschenbild ist genau eine die
ich glaube sehr stark nach vorne rückt
in krisenzeiten wie wir sie momentan ja
auch wahrnehmen also zukunft kommt viel
stärker in die gegenwart und das drüber
nachdenken über zukunft und was eben
auch wünschenswerte zukunft sind wenn
wir das gefühl haben das was wir als
normalität beschrieben haben ist
vielleicht gar nicht mehr so
wünschenswert oder wird eben durch
krisen sowieso nicht mehr in zukunft so
bleiben können also dieses krisenhafte
momentum das aufrütteln der routinen was
jetzt natürlich die krone krise noch mal
viel stärker gemacht hat was wir vorher
natürlich auch begonnen haben zu sehen
durch natürliche veränderungen die auch
zu fluchtursachen geworden sind wenn der
klimawandel sich schon deutlich zeigt in
anderen teilen der welt vielleicht mehr
als hier bei uns in deutschland oder
jetzt die zunehmende soziale spannung
dadurch dass die ungleichverteilung
dessen was wir an wohlstand schöpfen zu
stark geworden ist als wir haben ja
vorher schon gemerkt dass vieles im
umbruch ist und das sind natürlich genau
die zeiten wo diese fragen nach den
tieferen ja ich nenne das manchmal die
frage worum geht's eigentlich die hat
eine chance nach vorne zu rücken und
damit hat es natürlich eine chance sich
über solche dinge wie ein menschenbild
und was sie in uns an potenzialen
angelegt sehen überhaupt mal wieder
thematisieren und uns darüber
auseinandersetzen können
und genau das wollen sie auch schon an
einem neuen institut sie sind seit
november direktorin wissenschaftliche
direktorin eines neuen instituts mit dem
namen der new instituts beheimatet in
hamburg da wird auf 6000 quadratmetern
auch groß gedacht auch da will man den
gesellschaftlichen wandel denken
weiterdenken rund 35
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sollen da permanent gemeinsam
transdisziplinär forschen dazu kommen
gäste aus politik aus den medien aus der
wissenschaft der wirtschaft usw
wenn man nach vorne blickt und sich in
zehn jahren fragt hat sich die
investition in dieses riesige
forschungszentrum gelohnt
woran wird man den erfolg gemessen also
so groß sind wir gar nicht so klein und
fein
also wenn man sich über jahre nur für
einige forschungsinstitute sind 35
personen die zusammen denken dürfen aber
es ist natürlich gerade für eine
philanthropische investition ist es
natürlich eine größenordnung die wir
nicht häufig beobachten ganz klar und
genau das ist eben ja auch das schöne
dass jemand mit einer großen vision sagt
ich möchte mich dafür verwenden
ich möchte das was mir vergönnt wurde
mein vermögen ich vermag so etwas zu
gestalten dann auch in die richtung
ausrichten und anknüpfend an die frage
nach dem menschenbild und an den
potenzialen orientiert geht es wirklich
genau darum transdisziplinär zu denken
also die besten ideen aus
unterschiedlichen nicht nur kulturellen
räumen sondern auch disziplin und aus
der praxis zusammen zu bringen und immer
mit dem fokus auf das mögliche weil wir
das gefühl haben die krisen beschreibung
ist jetzt sehr stark und wir müssen
jetzt sehr stark auch in die richtung
arbeiten und aufzeigen was denn möglich
wirkt wenn wir auch bestimmte dinge sein
lassen also in dem strukturwandel sehen
wir immer sehr starke schauen wir mal
sehr stark auf das was nicht mehr geht
und sprechen von verlierern und
verliererinnen und das was wir alles oft
dass ich verzichten müssen und wir
möchten sehr stark eben den blick darauf
richten was denn eigentlich alles
entstehen kann wenn sich eine struktur
ändert heißt das ja auch dass etwas
neues wachsen kann und das ist genau der
focus mit dem wir unterwegs sind weil
wir glaube ich heute die geschichten des
gelingens aufbrauchen um wenn etwas
altes vergeht das neue was entsteht viel
viel stärker in den vordergrund zu
drängen und damit auch die motivation
darauf hinzuwirken
selbst wenn noch nicht jeder schritt
eindeutig klar das heißt für sie würde
das bedeuten erfolgreich wird dieses
institut sein wenn es hinreichend gute
geschichten des gelingens erzählen kann
genau einmal die guten geschichten das
gelingt wirklich auch neue ideen wir
merken ja manchmal dass es eigentlich
nur um setzt problematik ist mehr als
eine wissens problematik in vielen
bereichen wirklich auch zu überlegen wie
könnte konnte man noch mal mit neuen
allianzen mit einer neuen perspektive
mit einer ganz neuen idee jetzt nicht
nur technologisch gedacht sondern viel
auch sozial innovativ gedacht oder auch
kulturell gedacht dinge vorantreiben
also
sehr starken anteil eben
sozialwissenschaftlicher forscher innen
oder eben auch aus den
geisteswissenschaften
und natürlich geht es dann auch darum in
experimentier räumen da gibt es einmal
in hamburg vor ort schon eine erste
initiative wie kann wirklich stadt und
digitalisierung eine positive
stadtentwicklung wunderbar unterstützen
was bedeutet das für daten daten
eigentum daten in bürgerhand also diese
ganzen fragen kommen dort nach vorne und
gleichzeitig möchten wir das in anderen
bereichen auch tatsächlich experimentell
testen also dass imaginieren und das
experimentieren zusammenbringen
das finde ich jetzt gerade sehr
interessant weil ich nehm ich mir
überlegt habe wie sehr das denken
eigentlich wirklich wegweisend sein kann
also für sie ist ja eigentlich schon das
denken der zentrale motor des
gesellschaftlichen wandels
das haben sie auch deutlich gemacht in
einem anderen buch 2016 der great mein
schiff wo sie auch versucht haben zu
zeigen die serie eben umdenken müssen
mein schiff das stichwort und manchmal
denke ich dann aber dass wir aus
denkende zunft sage ich jetzt mal die
wissenschaft vielleicht das denken
überschätzen und dass es uns ja gelingen
muss das denken ins handeln zu bringen
also könnte es nicht sein dass wir uns
darüber einfach täuschen dass das denken
gar nicht so furchtbar wichtig ist
leider wenn es um zukunftsgestaltung
liegt ja ich glaube der punkt ist ganz
wichtig also im grunde geht ja die frage
dahin unter welchen bedingungen entsteht
in uns bereitschaft verantwortung zu
übernehmen
und da ist natürlich einmal das wissen
eine ganz wichtige beteiligung an diesen
prozess und das andere ist natürlich
aber auch mit zuversicht aus dem finden
von selbstwirksamkeit und gerade bei dem
buch war sie erwähnt haben gleich mein
schiff fand ich die übersetzung ins
deutsche sehr schwierig weil der begriff
meint ja mehr macht als nur das
kognitive zu umfassen das hat etwas mit
mit empfinden mit psychologie mit meint
fundes also mit dieser aufmerksamkeit
dieses sein in der welt zu tun
und genau deshalb uns eben nicht nur als
denkende sondern als empfinden gewesen
auch wahrzunehmen und das ist ja auch
eine wichtige diskussion in der
wissenschaft gerade auch im kontext
bildung dass es nicht nur darum geht
kognitive fähigkeiten zu entwickeln
sondern auch das ganze was wir in uns im
körperlichen angelegt haben
der interaktion angelegt haben bis hin
zu homöostase selbststeuerung in einem
unsicheren raum kritik zu äußern können
dass sie konstruktives also all das was
wir an weiteren fähigkeiten auch als
menschen im emotionalen und körperlichen
angelegt haben mit dem geistigen
zusammen zu denken
und damit ist es ja auch die gesamte
person die über gesamte mensch die im
mittelpunkt den von bildung und aus
meiner perspektive eben auch ein
potenzial das in der wissenschaft wieder
stärker zu machen
es gibt ja diese schöne idee das
zukunfts immer gestaltet oder sich
verändert bei design by diesel also wir
haben eigentlich die wahl wollen wie die
zukunft designen oder ins desaster
schlitten und dann ist völlig klar was
die leute wählen jeder sagt sofort neuer
wir wollen design auf gar keinen fall
desaster aus philosophin muss ich mir
dann aber manchmal ein bisschen
zerknirscht zugestehen dass man mal
genau das design ins desaster geführt
hat also denken wir beispielsweise an
eine idee wie den sozialismus den mann
am reißbrett sich ausgedacht hat designt
hat und genau die idee führte eigentlich
ins desaster
ja das spannende ist ja dafür alles
lebendige systeme sind also sowohl die
menschen als auch die natur um uns und
deshalb natürlich und das können wir im
moment auch sehr gut beobachten wo wir
alle anfangen so ein bisschen mehr auf
nicht lineare entwicklung auf nicht
prognostizierbare wendepunkte
rückkopplungsschleife unerwartete
konsequenzen die wir eben nicht im
designprozess schon vorher sehen konnten
mit denen konfrontiert werden und
deshalb ist diese idee einer lernenden
spezies eines adaptiven management
nennen wir das manchmal in der
transformationsphase ganz wichtig dass
ich eine idee habe eine annahme habe
auch wie sich ein system also ein
organismus eine familie eine lokale
kommune ein ganzes land wenn sie das
beispiel sozialismus jetzt nennen
verhalten wird und wie es sich anfühlen
wird darin zu agieren und auch zu
kooperieren
wenn das gar nicht so hinten rauskommt
wie wir uns das am anfang gedacht haben
dann sollten wir natürlich korrigieren
und das ist in vielen bereichen ja ganz
wichtig auch dann zu schauen wie
beispielsweise auch menschliche
evolution neuer empfindungen innovation
auch den ursprungszustand unter dem eine
idee sinnvoll gewesen ist so weit führen
dass wir wieder anpassen müssen und das
ist ja zum teil das was wir in der
ökonomie gerade sehr stark forcieren das
so sagen die idee von märkte schaffen
hat etwas sehr befreiendes gehabt in
einer feudalen aristokratisch
organisierten gesellschaft individuen
viele anbieter viele nachfrage können in
einer ganz anderen form entwicklung und
vor allem innovation und unternehmertum
et cetera vorantreiben und jetzt haben
wir aber die idee dass märkte das beste
gestaltungs instrument sind so weit
getrieben dass sie nicht mehr befreien
sondern für viele eben einschränkend
geworden sind und gleichzeitig schauen
wir viel zu wenig ob die strukturen die
wir heute noch märkten überhaupt noch
dieser idee von viele anbieter viele
nachfrage entsprechen
wir haben jetzt zum teil wieder so große
konzerne geschaffen beispielsweise dass
wir eigentlich nicht mehr davon sprechen
können dass hier an dem anbieter und
nachfrage in irgendeiner weise ein
gleichgewicht hätten was dann eben diese
marktentwicklung überhaupt möglich
machte weil die macht sehr ungleich
verteilt ist
das heißt einmal eine idee kann zu
extrem werden und damit das auflockernde
das befreiende verlieren und dann müssen
wir natürlich immer wieder schauen wie
sich die rahmenbedingungen verändert
haben
ob die ursprüngliche kraft und die
ursprüngliche vision einer idee heute
überhaupt noch mit den gleichen
instrumenten transportieren werden kann
nun gibt es natürlich auch denken und
denker die sagen perfekt wird diese welt
nie sein und vielleicht sind wir ja
schon in der bestmöglichen welt
angelangt wenn ihr ein bisschen
zurückgehen in der geschichte dann fällt
zum beispiel auf das in den 1930 er
jahren die philosophin simone weil
beispielsweise gefordert hat einen acht
stunden arbeitstag eine
gesundheitsvorsorge für alle bezahlten
urlaub das war eine total utopie und
siehe da heute haben wir das erreicht
oder denken sie an die forderungen von
john stuart mill den liberalen
philosophen mitte des 19 jahrhunderts
der gesagt hat der gleichstellung von
mann und frau haben wir noch nicht ganz
erreicht aber zumindest können auch in
der schweiz zum beispiel die frauen
mitbestimmen in der politik das heißt es
gibt natürlich viele die sagen
beispielsweise steven pinkl wir leben
längst in der bestmöglich in aller welt
sind was wollen die da jetzt groß
verändern
was entgegnen sie diesen personen naja
eigentlich finde ich es wichtig zu
wer definiert denn was die bestmögliche
welt ist und ist es wirklich jetzt eine
sehr plural definierte aussage ist es
sehr stark vielleicht eine wo wir
aktuell ja auch viele diskussionen haben
ältere weiße männer die diese form von
gesellschaftlicher entwicklung
vielleicht sehr positiv finde und auch
einen indikatoren satz wählen der für
sie gut aussieht aber für andere nicht
also haben wir ganz wichtige bewegungen
zum beispiel gerade in den people of
colour bewegungen wenn wir uns anschauen
wie die verteilung von dem wohlstand
aussieht wie die möglichkeit verteilt
ist auch gesellschaftlich mitzugestalten
und vielleicht mehr diversität
reinzubringen
dann kann man sagen wir haben ganz viel
erreicht aber wir sind natürlich noch
nicht da wo die personen die aktuell
sehr stark diskriminiert werden und mit
einem zu den rassismus konfrontiert
werden sagen das ist die beste aller
welten
also das ist für die natürlich eine
ansage
da kann ich das verstehen wenn das
jemand sehr privilegiert es macht aber
wir können doch nicht sagen
diese welt ist schon für alle vorhanden
und wenig sagen dass trends die genau
diese entwicklung ja in frage stellen
nicht heute schon sichtbar sind das
heißt ich kann nicht einfach aus seiner
vergangenheit extrapolieren und sagen
wenn wir das weiter gleich machen wie
wir es bisher gemacht haben wird für
alle auf einmal diese form von
lebenserfahrung materiellem wohlstand
etc verfügbar sein weil und das ist
jetzt der punkt wieder als ökologisch
informierte personen
argumentieren muss er einfach gar nicht
die ressourcen dafür haben und das ist
vielleicht der die allergrößte kritik
oder die auseinandersetzung zwischen
denjenigen die in richtung
nachhaltigkeit und klima und
biodiversität argumentieren zu sagen wir
möchten niemandem absprechen dass das
tolle ist wie die lebenserwartung
gestiegen ist dass wir viel mehr
menschen in bildung haben dass die
einkommen gleicher verteilt sind dass
wir viel mehr menschen auf einem
planeten weil wir viel mehr geworden
sind
grundversorgung erreicht haben aber es
ist eben nicht möglich das weiter so zu
betreiben und da ist die indikatoren
auswahl wieder sehr relevant weil viele
dieser arm personen die das sagen da war
mcafee im letzten jahr auch sehr
dominant eben sich nicht die
lebenszyklen anschauen und sich nicht
anschauen wie in den reichen ländern
viele der ressourcen die wir in anspruch
nehmen aus anderen territorien
und die dritte sache die wenig
berücksichtigt wird und ökosysteme
brauchen bestimmte regenerative
schleifen das heißt selbst wenn ich noch
ganz viel uran rc2 oder kohle im boden
habe ist es die atmosphäre die nicht
mehr müll aufnehmen kann und sind es die
wälder die ich nicht noch kleiner haken
darf und noch mehr abholzen darf wenn
wasser zyklen und biodiversität erhalten
werden sollen das heißt es fehlt uns
nicht an materiellen stoffen sondern wir
dürfen diese rückkopplungsschleife nicht
maximal torpedieren weil uns dann eben
ja die stabilen lebensbedingungen
abhanden kommen ja und das ist ja dann
so wie wenn man einen riesentanker wie
die titanic vor einem eisberg noch um
lenken will
das dauert extrem lang bis man den
großen tanker umgesteuert haben das
heißt es ist eigentlich jetzt der letzte
moment um wirklich noch was zu ändern
passiert eigentlich sehr deutlich in dem
buch dass es eine große dringlichkeit
gibt eben ins handeln zu kommen
transformation voranzutreiben
nun heißt ihr buch ja unsere welt neu
denken eine einladung und dass ich das
gelesen habe habe ich gedacht na ja das
klingt so freundlich müsste das buch
nicht heißen unsere welt neu denken last
call letzte durchsage mir ging es um
zwei wochen insbesondere in diesem buch
und zwar steht da ja wenn ich vorher
schon nachhaltigkeits forscherin gewesen
bin nicht unbedingt etwas ganz neues
drin sondern dieser wissens bestand ist
anders noch mal zusammen gefügt
viele haben gesagt sie finde es sehr
gelungen dass die ganz großen trends
miteinander in verbindung gebracht
wurden und damit eben auch andere
möglichkeiten sichtbar wurden wie wir
denn zum beispiel der ökologischen krise
begegnen könnten die einladung bestand
darin dass ich das gefühl hatte wenn
nicht viele von den bürger in
aufgeklärten gesellschaften und in
demokratischen prozessen selbst sagen
wir möchten etwas verändern wir haben
das verstanden wir gucken ehrlich hin wo
wir heute stehen und können dann die
trends abwenden und ganz viele positive
ideen entwickeln und die gibt es ja auch
das ist ja das wichtige nie zu vergessen
wie viel in vielen nischen nennen wir
das in der forschung für transformation
wieder es schon gibt die wirklich ganz
tolle neue technologien
ganz tolle zirkuläre prozesse sie kommen
im moment nicht in den markt und damit
in die breite weil die rahmenbedingungen
falsch gesetzt sind und das ist ja
eigentlich die positive botschaft und
diese rahmenbedingungen diese
politischen rahmen liegen zu verändern
das ist eine demokratische aufgabe und
deshalb ist es die einladung von uns
allen in unserem alltag mal vor allem
auch als bürger innen sich für politik
einzusetzen
die es vermag dann all das aus der
nische zu holen und in die neue
normalität führen zu können also nicht
zurück zu der normalität vor corona das
war nun wirklich welt risikogesellschaft
sondern in eine neue realität wo die
dinge von denen wir sagen das ist eine
wünschenswerte zukunft das ja das
spannende dass die wünschenswerten
zukunft und die die wir als
wahrscheinlich empfinden ein bisschen
auseinandergedriftet sind aber dem focus
wirklich drauf zu setzen wir können alle
daran teilhaben und er weiß aus meiner
sicht wichtig eine einladung
auszusprechen und stoff wieder eine
programmatik vorzuschlagen und da sollen
alle hinterher laufen weil wir werden
das adaptive brauchen wir werden das
kreative brauchen und das kollaborative
gewisse denkmuster die wir aber nutzen
in der problemlösung sind denkens davon
denen sie sagen die stammen eigentlich
noch aus dem beginn der industriellen
revolution das sind heute fast schon
toxische denkmuster könnte man sagen
denkmuster die wirklich abgelegt werden
müssen und sofort denkt man jetzt naja
wird jetzt maria göbel über den
elefanten im raum sprechen nämlich über
wachstum und sagen wachstum das brauchen
wir nicht mehr das können wir uns nicht
mehr leisten und das ist ja überraschend
sie sagen nicht nein wachstum brauchen
wir nicht mehr sagen bloß das wachstum
ist rückwärtsgewandt definiert wir
brauchen eine reformierung von wachstum
zb in sozialer hinsicht nicht mehr über
bruttonationalprodukt sprechen sondern
über bruttonationalglück zum beispiel
worum geht sie den wagen
ich finde das total spannend weil ich
habe das gefühl wir sind ja in einer
gesellschaft gelandet wo es so was wie
wachstum ismus sozialismus geworden dass
wir uns keine positive zukunft mehr
vorstellen können wo nicht irgendwie
mehr eine ganz zentrale rolle spielt und
dabei ist es doch so wahnsinnig wichtig
auch zuschauen und kann was ganz
beruhigen das haben
was denn eigentlich schon da ist und was
nicht mehr sondern vielleicht einfach
qualitativ entwickelt werden sollte und
deswegen ist es so wichtig zu schauen
was ist denn eigentlich so ein
bruttoinlandsprodukt oder
bruttonationalprodukt und das ja sehr
viel schöpfung positiv drin also wenn
umwelt zerstört wird und jemand muss
dafür bezahlt werden sie wieder
aufzuräumen ist das für das
bruttonationalprodukt im prinzip positiv
aber es ist natürlich für eine
gesellschaftliche entwicklung und eine
idee von fortschritt nicht positiv war
wie er stagniert sind bzw erste etwas
wieder herstellen mussten was vorher
schon gegeben war und deshalb ist es so
wichtig zu überlegen was sollte denn
wieder wachsen und beispielsweise auf
der ebene der verein nation ist gerade
die dekade der regeneration und
restauration der ökosysteme ausgerufen
worden
ganz wichtig um eben dieses stabilen
lebensbedingungen und das was dieser
bioreaktor erde uns jedes jahr schenkt
an wertschöpfung zu erhalten aber wir
müssen es nicht und wir können es dann
einfach nicht so belassen und das wieder
wachsen lassen wenn nicht jemand dafür
bezahlt wird da irgendwie zu
intervenieren
das heißt die ganze umformung des
planeten es ist das was wir im
bruttonationalprodukt messen anstatt zu
sagen vielleicht können dinge die gut
funktionieren auch einfach mal so sehr
hin wie sie bleiben damit können wir
dann eben auch die arbeitszeiten
reduzieren und menschen sich mehr auf
ihre gesundheit fokussieren gucken wie
ihre gesundheit und der ökosysteme
zusammengehören weil wir auch da wenn
wir überlegen was so kapitalformen in
der ökonomie sind sozialkapital
beispielsweise sind ja so institutionen
und funktionierende zusammenarbeit davon
immer mehr zu machen macht es ja nicht
besser können wir uns alle einig sein
dass sollte effektiv sein vielleicht
voller vertrauen sein dass er eine
kulturelle frage qualitative frage
menschen werden als humankapital
bezeichnen da geht es ja um bildung und
um fähigkeiten und um gesundheit
das wird irgendwann nicht immer mehr
sondern wir haben eben etwas wie
homöostase resilienz regeneration die da
rein gehören und deshalb finde ich den
begriff mehr es immer besser ist ja an
allen qualitäten dessen was wir an
zutaten für menschliche entwicklung
haben menschen und natur eigentlich
vorbei müssen sie beschreiben in dem
buch ja auch die sie selber groß
geworden sind als ein kind auf dem dorf
ihre eltern beides berufstätige
mediziner medizinerin
sie haben eine reform schule besucht
haben in einer sehr großen familie
eigentlich gelebt das war eine
hausgemeinschaft mit anderen personen
gemeinsam sehr ökologisch ausgerichtet
pazifistisch ausgerichtet sie schreiben
auch es gab eigentlich kaum nicolas kopf
aus kein fleisch
das heißt dieses mindset sag ich jetzt
mal was haben sie sozusagen von
kindsbeinen angeordnet sie haben zwei
töchter ich nehme an den boxen
vielleicht ganz ähnlich jetzt auf wie
vertrauensvoll sind sie dass sie mit
ihrem programm wirklich genügend andere
menschen anstecken können denn das ist
es ja was es braucht es braucht die
große massen an personen die diese ideen
die sie haben mit tragen ansonsten wird
sich nichts verändern
da mache ich mir im moment gar nicht so
eine sorgen darüber weil ich wirklich so
viele zuschriften bekomme aus allen
bereichen der gesellschaft und deswegen
glaube ich auch dass wir eben diese
vernunftbegabte wesen sind weil viele
erstmal durch dieses wissen daran
interessiert würden sich darüber
gedanken zu machen wie könnte ich denn
eigentlich weniger in diesem fall nicht
nachhaltig leben und je einfacher das
andere vor leben um so einfach mal
nichts nach also ich hab sie ja drei
motivationsfaktoren den menschen diese
bereitschaft verantwortung zu übernehmen
zu wecken und das eine so ein bisschen
das darf nicht mehr sein
wir sind dieses moralische auf wasser
matthias ende in seinen gerechtigkeit
theorien auch beschrieben hat das kann
doch nicht mehr sein oder kwami apa
beschrieben hat in der frage der ehre
irgendwann kommt dieser punkt von das
ist nicht mehr akzeptables verhalten und
das andere ist natürlich das innovative
das ist so im unternehmertum oder und
erfindergeist und dafür ja genial wenn
das ginge
und dafür brauche ich ja auch erstmal
eine beschreibung dessen was eine
wünschenswerte geschichte wäre wo ich
hin möchte
und der dritte punkt ist eben das
nachmachen das haben schon mal leute da
gemacht und deshalb kann ich das doch
auch ich gucke mir mal an wie dieses
umgesetzt haben und macht es nach und
wenn wir diese drei unterschiedlichen
motivationen punkte in resonanz bringen
und dann auch gucken für
unterschiedliche personen gibt es ja was
unterschiedlich ist was wirklich wirkt
die freude ist für fischer waren sehr
bei der moral
dann gibt es natürlich jetzt ganz viele
tolle initiativen auch aus
digitalisierung und nachhaltigkeit wie
bringe ich das zusammen wirklich diese
digitale revolution zur lösung der
nachhaltigkeits probleme einzusetzen
anstatt nur sehr viel geld zu machen
und das ist ja für mich gerade richtig
ermutigend wo überhaupt überall was
kommt und deshalb habe ich da gar nicht
so sorge und je mehr leute ihre eigene
idee einbringen und ihre eigene
motivation und für andere dann die
peergroup bilden um so mehr kriegen wir
diese ansteckung natürlich in der
gesamten gesellschaft hin
und viele haben jetzt ja gerade in
dieser pandemie auch die erfahrung
gemacht vielleicht muss es gar nicht
immer dass immer mehr sein sondern wenn
nicht mehr so viele angebots da ist kann
man sich gleich wieder bescheiden auf
das lokale auf die nachbarschaft ihr
kauft und nicht mehr so viel man braucht
auch fast keine kleider weil man gar
nicht mehr raus geht und so weiter es
gibt dieses vielleicht ein bisschen zu
diesem small is beautiful zurück und
zugleich wissen wir ja alle im grunde
genommen braucht der kapitalismus nicht
natürlich das gefühl des mangels der
kapitalismus sich darauf angewiesen dass
wir das gefühl haben ich habe zu wenig
ich brauch mehr
also kaufe ich es gibt ja sogar eine
ladenkette die heißt kauf dich glücklich
es genau die idee den mangel zu
überwerfen mit konsum
wie wollen sie das zusammen denken die
soll denn unsere welt noch stabil
bestehen reines von den arbeitsplätzen
her gedacht wenn die menschen aufhören
zu kaufen zu konsumieren
also da haben wir den ganz ganz
wichtigen punkt gemacht oder den ganz
wichtigen schritt den ich manchmal sehr
vermisse wenn wir zum beispiel über die
arbeit der zukunft sprechen anstatt die
zukunft der arbeit
das was wir getan haben ist die arbeit
der zukunft mit in den raum holen dass
wir überlegen wie sie vorher auch schon
erwähnt hat es gab mal den traum nur
noch acht stunden am tag zu arbeiten
warum ist jetzt nicht die möglichkeit
das haben ja auch ökonomen john maynard
keynes und so weiter voraus gesehen wenn
eigentlich die materielle versorgung
fiel durch maschinen etc gewährleistet
ist dann würden wir doch
natürlicherweise und das ist das
wichtige den dingen nach streben die wir
eigentlich immer vermissen weil wir so
viel arbeiten müssen und das ist kultur
das ist gutes verhältnis mit der familie
das ist einfach spaß haben was ja nicht
immer sehr ressourcenintensiv verein
muss dass all diese dinge von denen wir
sagen dieses freizeit und die müssen wir
uns irgendwie leisten können
die können sie erwachsen und die dinge
könnten wachsen ohne dass sie dem
planeten kosten müssen weil sie in
vielen bereichen genau nicht die
ressourcenintensive
land sein müssen und dieses viele
materielle zeug anhäufen das zeigt die
glücksforschung ja deutlich hat
vielleicht kurzfristig moment von
aufregung und hadern status konsum etc
ich muss dazu gehören und die sachen
auch tragen aber es macht uns nicht
intrinsisch froh und deshalb glaube ich
dass dieses zu überlegen was es
eigentlich auch eine arbeits modell der
zukunft welche tätigkeiten möchten wir
denn dass sie selbstverständlich werden
können dass wir dafür mehr zeit haben
gerade diese ganze debatte die durch
krone jetzt viel stärker den vordergrund
gerückt wird warum ist das
erstrebenswertes zwei eltern jeweils 40
stunden arbeiten und dann eigentlich
ihre kinder nur noch in dem zustand
sehen und betreuen können wo sie schon
ermüdet sind da gibt es ja ganz viel
spielraum wenn wir das ergebnis dessen
wie menschen leben wollen voran stellen
um dann zu sagen ja wir haben im moment
strukturen gebaut die damit eine
ökonomische krise auslösen würden wenn
wir den konsum runter fahren aber das
heißt ja wir können die ökonomischen
strukturen verändern
anstatt dass mensch und natur sich
zwangsläufig in einem hamsterrad
weiterentwickeln müssen was im grunde
genommen die substanz der lebendigen
organismen auf diesem planeten für das
funktionieren von menschgemachten
institutionen erodiert und das ist ja
das verrückte wenn man da einmal darüber
nachdenkt kommt man ja viel stärker da
rein zu sagen welche strukturen wollen
wir dann abschaffen damit wir alle
wieder mehr freiheit empfinden und wir
sind weniger veranlasst immer den finger
auf andere zu zeigen wenn die nicht dann
ich nicht und so weiter mich begeistert
vieles von dem was sie sagen und
manchmal merke ich dann plötzlich habe
ich schon leisen zweifel der mich
beschäftigt nämlich die frage
profitieren wir nicht alle extrem stark
davon dass es eben trotzdem diese andere
welt gibt diese welt in der ganz viel
geld nach wie vor gewählt wird und
produziert wird sie haben am anfang
erwähnt dass ein philanthrop krieg das
heißt er ein einräder norddeutsche räder
sehr viel geld eingeschossen hat in
diese stiftung die jetzt dieses new
institut trägt einen zweistelligen
millionenbetrag hat auch bereits vier
große institute an weltweiten
universitäten gesponsert reinecke zb
auch einmal bei uns über marx gesprochen
hat ist eine der professorinnen die auch
in einem solchen institut forscht und
von ihm profitiert und da stellt sich
doch die frage dieses geld
ich wurde ja in einem kapitalistischen
system das immer mehr erworben und
vergrößert und ganz viel philanthropie
ist so entstanden können die es uns
wirklich leisten zu sagen okay und das
überwinden wir jetzt wird es nicht so
sein dass alles was wir jetzt uns schön
denken können in sich zusammenstürzt
wenn dieser boden nicht mehr da ist der
boden ist ja ganz ganz spannend also
weil wir jetzt gerade auch anfangs über
zu diskutieren weil crypto währungen
beispielsweise sehr prominent auf der
bildfläche erscheinen
das sind ja eigentlich erfindungen das
sind eigentlich verträge zwischen
menschen ein versprechen du bekommst
soundsoviel wenn du ein anrecht
nachweisen kann ist ein auf den
banknoten in england steht ja
tatsächlich auf diesem papier drauf ich
verspreche dem träger dieses papiers den
gegenwert von 5 und oder wie auch immer
darauf steht zu geben ist ja einen
kontrakt der im grunde genommen keinen
wert in sich hat sondern dieses
vertrauensverhältnis besiegelt und das
ist geld also wir merken auch gerade das
starten im moment sehr viel geld drucken
besonders die staaten wo die währung die
sie raus geben in ihrer hand liegt oder
die sie benutzen in ihrer hand licht die
haben ja die möglichkeit jetzt ganz viel
mehr geld in umlauf zu bringen
und vieles was auf privaten konten
gelandet ist musste ja erstmal so auch
in die welt gebracht wenn also
geldschöpfung ist ja eine ganz andere
kategorie noch von dann dieses geld in
form von kredit zum schaffen von
mehrwert einzusetzen was sie beschrieben
haben also das heißt wie wie können wir
eigentlich ein versprechen diese kredit
logik will ja wahnsinnig viel
entwicklung freigesetzt hat als sie erst
mal in form von es muss nicht immer gold
wert dagegen sein und es muss nicht
immer perlen sein freigesetzt wurde das
ist ja eine energie und wenn wir geld
als diese form von energie wahrnehmen
und sagen das können durch
unterschiedlichen vertragsformen oder
auch alternative währungen wie sie
sowieso entstehen auch eventuelle
geschaffen werden dann muss es nicht
immer unbedingt erst durch dieses sehr
viel mehr schaffen sehr viel mehr die
werde umwelt sind um dann irgendwann
hinten raus zu kommen um dann wieder das
gute zu tun aber wir müssen ja
eigentlich das ist auch ein wichtiges
prinzip nicht du lässt also versuchen
ein bisschen weniger kaputt zu machen
auf dem weg der geldvermehrung
sondern geld sollte er das mittel zum
zweck sein und nicht auf einmal jede
form von ökonomische aktivität
eigentlich nur noch der geldvermehrung
dienen und diese du gut muss nach vorne
kommen zum schluss frau göbel sie kennen
ja nicht nur die ökonomie sehr gut und
sie nicht nur wissenschaftlerin sondern
sie waren auch eine weile lang ganz nah
dran an der politik sie haben nämlich
die bundesregierung die deutsche
bundesregierung beraten in umweltfragen
waren da in einer generalsekretärin
eines beirats für globale
umweltveränderungen jetzt zieht man oder
man redet viel darüber dass das pariser
klimaabkommen wahrscheinlich gescheitert
ist wie zuversichtlich sind sie noch
dass sie die politik rechtzeitig ins
boot holen können angesichts der
tatsache dass wir immer wieder sehen die
politik mal ist unglaublich langsam
ich habe die hoffnung aufgeben darf man
ja nicht also das ist ja wie war
klangfarbe gesagt hatte ich glaube nicht
unbedingt daran dass exakt das
herauskommt was ich mir wünsche sondern
ich weiß es jetzt das richtige zu tun
und es ist jetzt das richtige zu tun
klar zu machen dass diese ökologischen
fragen und die klimakrise etwas ist was
nicht mehr grün ist oder links ist
sondern dass es wirklich inzwischen
verstanden wurde es da um sicherheit
geht dass es da um auch gutes vorsorgen
das wirtschaften geht wir haben ja die
finanzmärkte gesehen und große
statements von finanzmarktakteuren die
gesagt haben das ist ein risiko was
inzwischen in der kreditvergabe im
eingepreist werden muss das heißt dass
bewusstsein an der stelle ist ja sehr
weit
und da ist im grunde genommen jetzt
wichtig diese stimmen aus der
gesellschaft vor allem aus der
wirtschaft stark zu machen die sagen wir
würden profitieren unsere
geschäftsmodelle unsere innovationen
würden profitieren davon wenn wir diese
rahmenbedingungen veränderten und die
globale gerechtigkeitsfrage und die
intergenerative gerechtigkeitsfrage
wirklich nach vorne bringen diese ganze
idee wir müssten verzichten
das wäre unangemessen zu sagen
deutschland ist zu drücken es kann ich
nur argumentieren wenn mir egal ist wie
der verhältnis das verhältnis unseres
fußabdrucks hier gerade auch historisch
betrachtet im verhältnis zu anderen
teilen der welt die sehr viel stärker
vom klimawandel betroffen sein werden
als wir und heute schon sind dann kann
ich nur sagen tieren
was ist der moralische moralische
grundlage der gerechtigkeitsfrage
und dann wird die zukünftigen
generationen in unserem eigenen land
natürlich genau die die auf der straße
stehen und es hoffentlich gehe ich davon
aus auch wieder tun werden wenn sie
dürfen da sehen wir noch einmal den
global zuschnitt des denkens dem sie
fordern meyer guckel ich danke ihnen
ganz ganz herzlich für dieses gespräch
und für die zeit die sich genommen haben
danke sehr
ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich und
wünsche noch eine schöne sendung die
welt neu denken darüber sprechen wir
heute doch wie kommt das neue eigentlich
in die welt der kulturwissenschaftler
jörg metelmann von der universität st
gallen sagt mit imagine ihring uns mit
transformers ganz schön technisch klingt
erweist sich bei genauerem blick aus
durchaus politisch wie wir zu denkt
künstlerinnen und künstlern werden
darüber sprechen wir jetzt im zweiten
teil der sendung herzlich willkommen
herr mittelmann finden dank für die
einladung
beginnen wir doch gleich mit dem imagine
ihring und den begriff hat walt disney
erfunden ist sozusagen der vater dieser
kleinen maus hier was ist denn immerhin
ihring und genauso seine hat die nicht
erfunden hat ihn aufgenommen und wie ein
guter unternehmer markenrechtlich
geschützt und zu einem produkt gemacht
dass wir kaufen können er hat creative
imagination verbunden mit technik und
know-how seinem engineering und hat uns
die freizeitparks die disney
freizeitparks geschenkt und gesagt was
immer wir uns da träumen können das
können wir bauen und dass seine
kreativität technik und die verbinde ich
mit diesen namen
und wie schon gesagt haben geht eben
darum sozusagen das denken dass sich
vorstellen zu verbinden mit dem
technischen know how sie haben einen
eigenen begriff dafür nämlich die
vorstellung wo die vorstellung
zusammentrifft mit der stellschraube
gerade der witz bei diesem begriff
engineering deswegen haben ihn harald
welt sondern ich auch gebraucht ist ja
dass er irgendwie so ein hinhörer ist es
ist jetzt immer jenny ist er ist
imagination ist es engineering und ich
hab mir überlegt wenn man das ein
deutschen wollte dann würde man
vielleicht die vorstellbar als man denkt
das geht richtung vorstellung und kommt
aber zur stellschraube oder man spricht
vom ein bildungs kalkül
der einbildungskraft seinem kalkül also
es bringt etwas zusammen was wir
gemeinhin nicht zusammen denken und das
was uns daran interessiert hat war
eigentlich mehr der aspekt dass wir es
aus diesen markenrechtlich geschützten
kleinen privaten kreativbereich
zurückholen wollen in das kollektive
nachdenken darüber wie wir als
gesellschaft kreativ sein kann und
deswegen haben sie diese maschine ring
auch auf titel gewählt für das buch das
sie eben zusammen mit harald welzer
herausgegeben haben und waren auch texte
geschrieben haben
nun kann man sich ja fragen wunderbar
ich mag davor solche wortspielereien was
ist daran die tiefere bedeutung wenn die
zukunft denken wollen klären wer was ich
glaube zunächst mal ist es begriffs
politik was uns fehlt glaube ich aus
meiner sicht in transformations- diskurs
ist stärker darüber nachzudenken wie wir
das alte loslassen bevor wir zum neuen
kommen können also es geht
schlechterdings darum dass wir ein
bisschen gefangen sind auch in
bestimmten sehr überzeugenden sehr guten
geschichten davon wie wir leben sollen
und die vielen guten ideen die wir haben
die kommen nicht so richtig zum zuge
weil immer schnell die rückkehr zur
guten normalität siehe corona krise wir
wünschen uns nichts mehr als wieder in
die normalität zurückzukommen und die
begriffs politik sagt eigentlich lasst
uns neue begriffe finden mit denen wir
denken können die uns räume öffnen in
die wir uns bewegen wollen im
engineering ist einer davon weil er sagt
es geht nicht nur um engineering es geht
darum dass wir uns vorstellen wollen wie
wir leben wollen
andere begriffe kollege andreas weber
hat ihn stark macht im moment zu sagen
wir brauchen eine neue lebendigkeit wir
müssen raus aus diesem waren
fetischismus aus dem konsum denken das
terrestrische von bruno latour ist so
eine wurde auch den begriff von egro
sozusagen haarwachstum einfach nischen
denkräume zu öffnen indem wir andere
begriffe und vor allem auch andere
geschichten und zu erzielen und diebe
einzelne diese begriffe waren die
nachher noch sprechen vielleicht noch
einmal zuerst die idee dass ihr altes
loslassen müssen das kann natürlich
durchaus schmerzhaft sein
nicht zuletzt auch deswegen weil ihr
gerne am alten festhalten weil das ja
eigentlich sehr attraktiv war das hat
der soziologe andreas ragwitz sehr gut
beschrieben indem er gesagt hat es ging
eigentlich lange zeit um eine politik
des positiven wir haben
ja immer die geschichte erzählt von
wachstum von entwicklung von mehr welt
reichweite von emanzipation von
aufklärung alles hat geklappt und
geglänzt
und jetzt kommt es zur politik des
negativen klimakrise pandemie
finanzkrise also das alte loslassen ist
nicht besonders schön wenn dieses
negative da vorne
vor uns steht genau dass ich wie sie
beziehungsweise wie andreas es geht
letztendlich darum dass wir aus einer
verzichts erzählung also dass alles was
jetzt kommt ist negativ im sinne
verzicht auf etwas was wir hatten zu
einer freiheit zu erzählen kommen also
dass wir das was wir gestalten können
positiver besetzen können das ist glaube
ich eine ganz große aufgabe und das
bedeutet dass wir vielleicht auch das
was uns so weit gebracht hat was uns so
reich gemacht hat was uns diesen
unglaublichen gesellschaftlichen lebens
standard ermöglicht hat also von
rechtssicherheit bis zu der konsum
freiheit dass wir uns da auch noch mal
angemessen davon verabschieden
einer meiner studierenden hatte die ganz
schöne idee wie ich finde gute idee zu
sagen etwas ähnliches wie die
wahrheitskommission in südafrika wo es
nicht ums urteilen geht es geht nicht
darum jemanden zu verurteilen dafür was
er an klimasünden oder ähnliches gemacht
hat sondern wir erzählen uns nochmal wie
ist das gelaufen was war daran gut was
war daran schlecht und wir können dann
gemeinsam das gute nehmen und
weitermachen also wir brauchen auch
bessere abschieds rituale also eins
davon haben wir auch im buch das es auch
um große inszenierungen eigentlich
perfomances des loslassens geht das kann
man nicht individuell das sind rituale
gesellschaftliche rituale
das spürt man ja schon ganz stark dass
dieses thema genie ring wie die dass
sich vorstellen gemeinsam mit harald
welzer aber auch in einem eigenen
beitrag etwas poetisches hauten sie
sagen auch im grunde genommen geht es um
eine neue poetologie es geht um andere
herstellungsweise wir alle sind in der
welt geworfen in die zeit und die
zukunft ist offen und wiederholt sich
nicht das ist so da kommt das ganze
risiko management her dass wir aus den
finanzmärkten kenne niemand weiß was
kommt niemand wusste dass wir seit gut
einem jahr in dieser situation leben wo
wir uns mit masken quasi durch unsere
welt bewegen kann niemand
so sagen der punkt auf den mann bei dem
engineering dann zu gehen kann ist
wie wollen wir diese offenheit gestalten
also das haben sie gemacht das
politische ist eigentlich eine
gestaltungsweise und eine poetik
bedeutet immer innerhalb bestimmter
regeln
denken sie zum beispiel daran wie man
ein sonett verfasst hat die regel poetik
des 17 und 18 jahrhunderts und im
engineering alt poetologie ist ein
nachdenken über diese unterschiedlichen
arten des herstellers und sagt wir sind
nicht naiv und dumm darüber was geht und
was nicht geht wir haben bestimmte
leitplanken an denen wir uns orientieren
können und dem sinne schlagen wir vor
dem begriff als eine poetologie zu
verstehen innerhalb bestimmter denkräume
sich zu bewegen
das heißt nicht es einzuschränken aber
es sagt ein bisschen gefangen auch nicht
bei null an
und eigentlich ist ein teil dieses denkt
rahmens der liberalismus das haben sie
auch sehr deutlich warum machen sie
dieses zugeständnis oder warum ist genau
das jetzt teil dieser leitplanke
naja weil natürlich eine freiheitliche
gesellschaft die von selbstbestimmten
individuen ausgeht auch im sinne der
aufklärung die autonomie eigene
denkfähigkeit eigene gestaltungsräume
nutzen zu können ist ein sehr hohes gut
verfassungsrechtlich ist gut und das
braucht unbedingt eine gesellschaft die
von mündigen individuum getragen werden
soll
das andere ist ein bisschen was sich
quasi ökonomisch oder politisch
ökonomisch damit verbindet und da müssen
wir tatsächlich noch mal die welt vom
kopf auf die füße stellen indem wir
nicht quasi uns als transformations-
forscher utopisten schimpfen lassen die
sagen ihr versprecht dinge die er nicht
halten sondern dass wir umgekehrt sagen
euer vermeintlicher realismus der
realismus eines globalisierten
wettbewerbs einer globalisierten
kompetitive tät einer endlosen
ausbeutung von ressourcen das ist
utopisch
und es ist erwiesenermaßen utopischen ja
sogenannte earth overshoot day ist in
der schweiz 2020 g8 also der zeitpunkt
an dem sozusagen die ressourcenverbrauch
zins wenn man mit leine möglich einer
welt genau jährlich sich wir produzieren
den ressourcen sind in der schweiz am 8
mai aufgebraucht jahre davor war es der
siebte monat gar keinen so großen
gefällt
diese wirtschaftsweise ist utopisch also
ganz wörtlichen sinne sie ist nicht von
dieser welt
das ist eigentlich interessant weil
viele ja immer sagen ist es nett zu
träumen von irgendwie gemeinsam
kartoffeln im garten anpflanzen so aber
es gibt auch noch realpolitik und sie
sagen jetzt entschuldigung eure
realpolitik ist utopisch ist
erwiesenermaßen utopisch also niemand
alkis tropisch sie wird desto fisch wir
sind offensichtlich gerade an diesem
tipping point wo diese utopie die uns
nochmal großen reichtum beschert hat ist
man gibt auch gute gründe ein moderates
wachstum im sinne der unterstützung weil
sie eine unternehmerisch denkenden
gesellschaft weiterhin zu fördern wir
müssen raus aus dem was christoph
binswanger den den wachstumsdrang nennt
wir müssen raus aus dieser erzählung des
meeres schneller des weiter weil dafür
ist schlechterdings unsere welt nicht
groß genug
sie haben mir im vorfeld gesagt dass sie
und das haben sie auch mitgebracht eine
ausgabe noch haben eine erste ausgabe
schon die grenzen des wachstums sieht
man dass sich interessante 1972
erschienen
also das was jetzt gesagt haben dass
dieses wachstum nicht ewig weiter geht
dass der planet sehr traumbild wird wie
auf diesem bild wenn ihr nicht sozusagen
uns neue arten des wirtschaftens aus
denken ja keine neue idee waren die
leute damals noch nicht auf eine neue
poetologie angewiesen oder ist das
gedicht die politik eben doch zu schwach
wenn es darum geht realpolitik zu machen
sage ich jetzt noch mal genau das ist
interessant 1970 meinem geburtsjahr ist
zuerst einmal das jahr in dem die
weltmeere ressourcen pro jahr verbraucht
als die natur als sozusagen naturkapital
diese zur verfügung stellt also quasi in
meiner lebenszeit gehen wir immer mehr
ins minus bis hin zu dem besagten
overshoot day ein problem scheint zu
sein dass wissen alleine nicht wirklich
zu veränderungen führt wir kennen das
aus der psychologie den sogenannten
value action gibt dass leute die quasi
form coop gefragt werden werden sie
jetzt bio fleisch kaufen
aus sozialer opportunität sagen ja
natürlich und wenn man drin steht kauft
man vielleicht doch ein etwas sozusagen
konventioneller hergestelltes vielleicht
also das wissen alleine übersetzt sich
nicht automatisch
ein besseres handeln auch moral
übersetzt sich nicht automatisch in
handeln das ist die erzielung von
verzicht von der wir schon kurz
gesprochen haben ich glaube es geht
darum das was auf uns zukommt im sinne
dieser poetik wirklich als ein
gestaltungsraum für viele zu öffnen und
diesen raum sozusagen das auch
experimentellen ausprobierens da habe
ich ein bisschen darauf wert gelegt in
meinem beitrag zu sagen das hat was mit
ästhetik das hat was mit spiel und
experiment zu tun dass sich die einzelne
der einzelne darin wiederfinden darf und
auch bauen sie ein ganz schönes beispiel
in ihrem beitrag sie haben auch die
postkarte dazu mitgebracht das kunstwerk
metro pa des künstlers stefan
frankenberger vielleicht mögen sie ganz
kurz erklären was das genau ist man
sieht ein u bahnnetz genau und man sieht
ein u bahn netz und das ist nicht zürich
oder berlin sondern das ist unser
kontinent europa herr stephan
frankenberger hatte die irgendwie
wunderbare idee quasi dass die
europäische mobilität fühlbar zu machen
mit einem relativ einfachen kniff den
wir quasi aus der darstellung von urban
netzen can london tube berlin anderes
wir alle haben ein bild davon weil es
auch so ein bisschen zu unserer modernen
erfahrung gehört großstädtisch zu leben
und hat die idee farbige linien durch
europa zu ziehen verbunden zu einem
quasi gefühls großraum europa in dem ich
mich in einer u bahn sitzen sehe die
mich wahrscheinlich wenn man das
umrechnet würde in circa zwei stunden
von zürich nach barcelona bringt in
dieser idee und dann dann fühlen sie mal
rein was das heißt sich zu überlegen ob
man am abend auf die ramblas fährt er
neben zunächst mal das gefühl ich rede
jetzt nicht über großprojekte und dass
das unbedingt schweizer ingenieure bauen
sollten und bestimmt nicht die leute vom
berliner großflughafen alles geschenkt
sondern versuchen sie mal rein zu gehen
und dieses gefühl und diese poetische
kraft diesen raum zu öffnen das ist
glaube ich das besondere was dem gelingt
aber worum es uns glaube ich
gesellschaftlich geht und trotz
diversität ein wir zu schaffen weil ich
habe mir dann überlegt wir haben ja in
zürich zum beispiel keine u bahn aber
wenn man an paris denkt ist natürlich
was ganz anderes je nachdem wo man
aussteigt die quartiere sind enorm
divers und trotzdem weiß jeder sofort
das alles ist paris und dieses bild
macht mit einem so was wie
sankt petersburg und barcelona alles ist
irgendwie vernetzt das ist schon ein
sehr interessantes bild liegt auf dieser
linie und ich fahre sie gleichsam ab und
ich verbinde das auch mit meinem körper
mit so einer somatischen erfahrung jeder
von uns weiß wie es sich anfühlt in der
u-bahn zu sitzen und quasi die stationen
an sich vorüber ziehen zu lassen und in
diesem imaginären raum einzutreten wie
man jetzt mit einer anderen kultur mit
einer anderen sprache mit freunden die
man so sehen kann wie man zusammenkommen
kann und ich glaube dieses moment was
diese kleine dieses kleine beispiel
diese karte schafft es mich eigentlich
zu einem wandernden also vom betrachter
zu etwas zu machen was die zu jemandem
zu machen wir in diesen raum eintaucht
und der diesen raum fühlt und in ihnen
lebt damit das ist die entscheidende
pointe zu sagen so müssen wir uns auch
quasi auf die auf uns zukommende zukunft
zu bewegen nicht als leute die darauf
warten dass sich neue shopping
opportunities eröffnen sondern als
gestaltende die wandern sie durch den
raum gehen den wir haben und den wir neu
definieren können
was mich irgendwie fasziniert ist dass
man merkt sie haben eine hohe affinität
zur kunst zu design und das ist ja bei
vielen transformations- experten oder
eben designern so auch harald welzer hat
zum teil diesen hintergrund mit den
sieben zusammenarbeiten kann man was
schon so weit gehen und sagen eigentlich
ist die kunstwelt der ort an dem zukunft
gedacht wird und auf die man auch mehr
hören müsste man zukunft denkt na ja
kunst ist ja auch nicht mehr unschuldig
wir haben natürlich die gleiche
ökonomisierung im kunstbereich wie wir
das in allen anderen gesellschaftlichen
bereichen haben also es gibt nicht so
etwas wie das gelobte land wo wir jetzt
nachlegen gehen müssten aber ich glaube
man kann wenn wir kunst ein bisschen
weiter fassen von ästhetik und
ästhetische erfahrung sprechen
das ist schon darum geht das ist etwas
mit unserer sinnlichkeit mit unserem so
sein zu tun haben muss und den von ihnen
schon erwähnten begriff transformer habe
ich auch sehr bewusst wiederum theorie
strategisch gewählt weil ich in
positionieren wollte eigentlich gegen
die stille machtübernahme durch die
algorithmische vernunft also quasi durch
die neuen lehrstühle die es gibt für
informatik die durchdringung sämtliche
lebensbereiche
durch die informatiker die
transformative sagt nein wir sind diese
organismen wir sind auch dieser
gesellschaftliche metabolismus und in
dieser sinnlichkeit in dieser
körperlichkeit das ist das was uns
besonders macht
also wiederum ein wortspiel
transformation und informatik zusammen
genommen also das sehr technische das
programmierbare das berechenbare
zusammengenommen mit dem spielerischen
sicht transformieren genau genau das ist
so ein bisschen das anliegen auch dieses
quasi der gesamt agenda die die glaube
ich da dahinter steckt dass wir eben
sowohl uns überlegen müssen wo gehen wir
hin und da helfen uns vielleicht
methoden die man aus der kunst kennt da
helfen uns erfahrungen die wir aus der
ästhetischen aus der ästhetik und aus
der ästhetik kennen aber es gibt darum
nicht naiv zu sein das ist die andere
seite das wir natürlich gewisse nicht
nur planetarische sondern auch soziale
grenzen haben wir uns sehr bewusst sein
müssen
jetzt haben sie gerade ganz viel den
begriff wir benutzt und das ist eine
frage die ich vorhin auch mit frau göbel
erörtert habe die kombi eigentlich zu
diesem gemeinsamen wie und können wir
überhaupt davon ausgehend dass wir
gemeinsam die welt neu denken oder
gestalten können weil china ganz anders
denkt europa das silicon valley anders
aus eine waldorfschule was wie die
seinen wie er denn diese sie hier wie
denken wir dieses wir ganz großer ganz
wichtiger punkt und alles was wir im
moment sehen wie gesellschaftlich
miteinander umgegangen wird wie wir
diskutieren zeigt wie schwierig die
aufgabe ist dieses dieses wir ist
zerbrochen
das ist zu großen teilen auch aus guten
gründen zerbrochen weil es eigentlich
eine weiße erzählung ist die sich in
großen teil noch einfach
kolonial gestaltet hat das muss man ja
sehr einfach sagen viel von diesem
wohlstand den wir haben gut auch darauf
auf dass er sich dinge aneignet die uns
nicht zustünden
und dieses wir zu bauen ist ein ganz
zentraler punkt räume zu schaffen in
denen menschen zueinander kommen die
sagen wir können zusammen so das kann
ganz konkret gesagt kleinere landkreise
ortschaften das können kommunen seien
die macht der städte auch in diesem
ganzen transformations- diskurs und dass
es darum geht miteinander in austausch
zu gehen und das was zum beispiel in der
antizipation forschung also mal zu
fragen was sind denn eure annahmen
darüber was wir tun was sind denn eure
werte eben jenseits dessen was uns immer
erzählt wird es gibt ökostrom und es
gibt wachstum und die würde des menschen
dass auch garantiert aber jenseits
dessen ist gar nicht so klar wie das
aussehen soll
also hier beginnt das tatsächlich sehr
grundlegend auf sozusagen einem anderen
verständnis von den grund und boden auf
dem wir stehen und da kommt ein anderer
wichtiger begriff mit reinen haben sie
schon erwähnt nämlich das terrestrische
von bruno latour einem französischen
philosophen und soziologen der hat das
terrestrische manifest geschrieben und
dieses terrestrische meint genau das
also einerseits eine verwurzelung wieder
im lokalen aber eben nicht dieses blut
und boden thematische was zum teil bei
heidecker anklingt nicht das
nationalistische sondern mehr das
verwurzelte dass auch der sorge wirklich
wieder raum gibt um das konkrete andere
genau also es gibt glaube ich latour der
da enorm einflussreiche nicht zuletzt
mit diesem stichwort darum zu sagen
sieht ja das terrestrische als einen
neuen traktor wie er es nennt wir hatten
ganz lange die von ihnen auch vorhin
erzählte geschichte wir haben einen
vektor und der weg erzählt auf
globalisierung globalisierung ist
fortschritt und es gibt eine
modernisierungs freundes gibt die
konservativen die bleiben da hinten es
gibt die progressiven die sind da vor
und er sagt eigentlich sehr überzeugend
nein wir haben einen weiteren vector das
ist das was er dann eben das
terrestrische nennt auch das sehr
begriffs politisch bewusst gewählt zu
sagen ich brauche einen neuen begriff
von mir ich zitiere verblüffender
originalität
das muss zunächst mal verwirrend
irgendwas was ist denn das jetzt tut
sich damit schwer das öffnet den raum
und er sagt nein ist es nicht quasi das
lokale der afg oder des front national
und es ist auch nicht die globalisierung
die abfahrt dass wir bald neue märkte
aufmachen sondern es ist ein sich neue
werden ist quasi der räume in die ich
gestellt wenn du das kennen wir alle ich
meine das sind die räume in denen wir
wohnen das sind auch die transit räume
wenn man pendler ist was ist eigentlich
mit dieser strecke wenn ich in bern
arbeitet und in zürich wohnte was ist
das eigentlich für ein raum durch die
nicht jeden tag fahre was ist für mich
das sozusagen erholungsgebiet dass mir
in der nähe ist und ich glaube er
plädiert dafür zu sagen wir müssen uns
dieser grundlage dieses grundes auf dem
wir stehen neu bewusst werden ohne dabei
quasi das heimatliche ab zu feiern
die bindung ist wichtig aber ich bin
zugleich entgrenzt in der welt es geht
darum glaube ich bei diesen dritten
attraktor nicht zu vergessen dass wir
modern sind aber zugleich zu sehen
modernisieren bedeutet diese sozusagen
fortschritts geschichte ad absurdum
weiterführen deswegen sagt der
ökologisierung stadt modernisiert und er
hat die idee einer neuen sozial
choreografie er beschreibt das auch so
dass es nicht einfach nur darum geht die
figuren im theaterraum neu zu
installieren und rum zu schieben sondern
sozusagen das theater mitspielen zu
lassen also den den raum mitzudenken im
ganzen
das klingt ja erstmal total verrückt
vielleicht können die dazu noch offen
ja das ist so ein bisschen geht auf die
idee auch ein bisschen ein liebe vorhin
hatten als wir über mitropa gesprochen
haben beziehungsweise über diese idee
dass der betrachter zum wanderer wird
latour wählt die metapher des theaters
eine uralte
darstellung bildlichkeit für das was wir
menschen zu tun und sagt wir alle gehen
davon aus das ist quasi eine bereitete
bühne gibt und auf die treten wir und
lernen skripte auswendig und sprechen
eine rolle und oder rezitieren eine
rolle untersagten sei dessen mal nicht
so gewiss denn auf einmal kommt die der
scheinwerfer entgegen oder die bühne
hebt sich und zwar nicht weil es so
choreografiert ist sondern einfach weil
und das ist sein bild die bühne selbst
beliebt es sie wird selber akteur und
das ist für ihn quasi das neue an diesen
sogenannten anthropozän wir haben einen
neuen akteur der selbst tätig ist und
der unsere raum zeit die wir für so
stabil halten
immer wieder brüchig macht und das
stellt uns vor herausforderungen die
familie gesprochen wie wir das neue
denken oder vielleicht eher poetisch
erfinden zeichnen entwerfen und sie
haben am anfang aber auch gesagt es geht
nicht nur darum dass neue zu denken
sondern auch alte ideen loszulassen und
haben sie das stichwort dessay groß also
des wachstums erwähnt des niederländers
van den bergh und sein punkt ist ja so
ein bisschen so wie es agnostiker gibt
die sagen es ist gar nicht wichtig ob
ich gläubig bin ob es gott gibt oder ob
es gott nicht gibt wir wissen es auch
gar nicht sondern wir rechnen erst mal
ohne die idee gottes so sagt er wir
sollten aufhören immer zu denken
es gibt was wir brauchen wachstum oder
gesunden wachstum abschaffen sondern mal
denken ohne überhaupt wachstum mit
einzubeziehen verstehe ich das richtig
verstehe ich das auch genau also das
plädoyer ist eigentlich nicht zu sagen
ich bin für oder gegen wachstum er sagt
selber es gibt gute gründe für wachstum
zu sein da können wir vielleicht gleich
noch mal drauf kommen das teile ich auch
sage er sagt es geht um die kenngröße es
geht um die kenngröße gdp gross domestic
product oder bruttoinlandsprodukt weil
sie eigentlich nicht das ist worum es
uns geht
sie müssten nicht unsere persönliche
zufriedenheit siem ist nicht unser glück
ist nicht die zeit die wir mit familie
zu bringen können sie müssen nicht ob
mein beruf mich in den burnout treibt
oder ob er mir zur selbstverwirklichung
verhilft sondern sie misst eigentlich
blöd gesagt wenn es auf der autobahn
einen unfall gibt mit mit drei toten und
vier schwerverletzten das wir
fünf neue autos brauchen und dass wir in
krankenhäusern dienstleistungen
erbringen um diese menschen gesund zu
machen
das heißt auch dass wird quasi zu einer
volkswirtschaftlichen größe obwohl wir
gesellschaftlich betrachtet sagen würden
ist das das worum es hier eigentlich
geht also es geht nicht per se darum
wachstum in frage zu stellen sondern es
geht darum welchen fetisch charakter die
zahl angenommen hat und das bestätigt
sich jetzt in der aktuellen corona und
post corona hoffentlich post corona
diskussion wieder gibt es andere
fetische die hier verabschieden sollten
das ist eine sehr gute frage ich glaube
was wir überdenken könnten was du
überdenken könnten ist unsere
einstellung zur technologie das ist ein
bisschen die frage inwiefern ist jede
technologische innovation auch eine
soziale innovation und müssten wir nicht
stärker zusammen denken wie das was uns
technisch möglich wäre auch etwas wird
was uns im gesellschaftlichen
zusammenleben persönlichen zusammenleben
größer macht uns möglichkeiten gibt denn
es geht ja nach wie vor glaube ich immer
noch darum zu sagen wir brauchen eine
größtmögliche zahl von anbindung an
mögliche lebensweisen also dass wir uns
quasi nicht in richtung eindimensionalen
menschen platz werk der mensch
isolierter mensch bewegen der zwei super
vernetzt ist aber eigentlich nicht mehr
in lebendigen austausch verhältnis
entsteht dass man an dieser frage ein
bisschen weiter denken könnte das ist
glaube ich ein großes thema gerade für
meine jungen studierenden ist natürlich
dass das habitat das ist das wo sie
herkommen und zugleich merken sie jetzt
auch wie komisch das eigentlich ist wenn
man sich die ganze zeit nur auf
bildschirmen begegnet da ist dann
plötzlich der mensch wieder ganz im
zentrum roms es ja so dass im silicon
valley für viele der ort par exellence
wenn es um innovation geht da wird wenig
soziale innovation geschaffen wenn ich
sie richtig verstehe jetzt auch darum
gehen sich da wiederum mit imagination
eben nicht nur technische innovation zu
denken sondern auch soziale innovationen
also man muss natürlich sagen dass kaum
etwas unser leben so sehr verändert hat
wie ein
medien technologische veränderungen
durch die smartphones also es gibt eine
welt vor dem 9
januar 2007 es gibt eine welt danach
silicon valley ist natürlich sehr groß
ist sehr vielgestaltig man kann glaube
ich sehr grundsätzlich allgemein sagen
was die neuen technologien
mehr noch eigentlich als die
personalcomputer quasi der generation
steve jobs und bill gates geschafft
haben über die smartphones ist die
vollendung sozusagen der computer
gesellschaft das was peter drecker schon
mitte des letzten jahrhunderts den ex
zur seite genannt hat die nächste
gesellschaft ist eine des computers und
wir alle sind ausgestattet mit
wahnsinnig intelligenten und wahnsinnig
potenten geräten und natürlich hat es
das sehr hat das unseren alltag
verändert wer den führenden social daher
kennt weiß wie kritisch selbst die
zauberlehrlinge darf ich sie nennen
heute auf das gucken was sie getan das
heißt nicht dass sie es alles hätten
sehen können aber ich glaube es regt uns
dazu an oder gibt uns die aufgabe dass
wir das stärker mit einbeziehen
mit welchen vorstellungen wie ihr die
schlösser der zukunft bauen sollten
das wird noch einiges zu reden und zu
denken geben nicht gedanke mich ganz
herzlich für dieses gespräch ermitteln
dann sehr gerne vielen dank wer nicht
nur weiterdenken sondern auch weiter
lesen mag diese beiden bücher verlosen
die mit einer mail an philosophie besser
als punkt ch sind sie dabei auch meine
kollegen von kulturplatz denken über die
zukunft nach im podcast der sendung
kontext fragen sie ob wir bald alle
kartoffeln im eigenen garten anpflanzen
und wie das geschäft mit der mode
nachhaltig wird nächste woche sind
philosophie und religion gemeinsam
unterwegs und zwar im reich des tantra
und 10.30 sehen sie einen film zum thema
ab 11 uhr gehen union und der
tantrischen energie in einer speziellen
sternstunde auf den grund und jetzt
gleich gehts zur kritiker runde zum
diesjährigen schweizer filmpreis großes
kino wie immer so viel schönes programm
kann ich nur sagen ich hoffe es ist
etwas dabei für sie eine gute zeit bis
bald
[Musik]